MercadoLibre is the largest Latin American e-commerce platform
providing solutions for payments, transfers, credits,
and classifieds for all the users operating through our platform.
We had a lot of downloads
but too many users were uninstalling the app overall
because of installation size and performance
since many of them
have lower end mobile devices.
We looked back at our code to better compile
the app for different architectures.
We had, for example, 30 APKs.
In our code, we did several things like reducing
the app’s external libraries,
that we were using at the app.
The app’s installation size shrank from 40 MB to about 10 MB
since we made those changes,
that was immediately reflected
in the installation and uninstallation rates.
My advice for any developer
looking to build an app
for a market like Latin America
is to pay special attention
to both the app’s download size and also its install size.
We like to build games that appeal
to a wide audience,
but also showcase something new
and innovative.
Fanatee’s most famous
game is “Stop.”
Stop has over 15 million Android downloads.
And today, “CodyCross” has even
more active users than “Stop.”
Localization is important for any mobile game.
We end up re-building a game
from the ground up
every time we launch it in a new country,
so both the translation of text
and the building of puzzles are done
very carefully,
all of this has a big impact on our ratings.
Developers’ main challenge in Latin America
is building and scaling a global business.
Latin American cultures are often too focused
on local economies.
This is especially true in Brazil
due to its huge size and population,
but the business of apps and games
is more global in nature.
You must shape your product
to be successful in all those countries.
In the Latin American market, 70% of persons were overweight.
And only 3% of people had access to gyms.
With InstaFit users can without inconvenience,
without spending too much, without having to go to a gym,
they can have routines in the comfort of their home,
all able to be completed in about 20 sq ft
and without equipment.
Last year, we grew 450% with our Android subscriber base
due to the fact that we hired a better team of internal developers
and we started doing much more optimization experiments
in user acquisition and user retention
exclusively on Android.
One of our experiments included changing
our trial period from 7 days to 30 days.
And that had an immediate impact
of a 25% increase in the volume of our free trials.
Understanding your users and supporting
them through their experience with the app
lets you build a business
that is growing with a loyal user base
that stays with you for a long time.
Mobills is a free platform and app,
which people can use to take control
of their finances.
However if users want to access
all the app’s features,
they pay a monthly subscription.
This year we saw a spike in growth
for Android subscriptions.
Until the middle of the year, we saw growth
in more than 55% of active subscriptions.
That happened because we implemented
new tools.
After we implemented the grace period,
which gives users seven days to resolve
any payment issues,
we saw the number of involuntary churn drop 40%
We also recognized a problem
in just how many of our users were using
our application for free
over extended periods of time.
By coordinating the introductory
price with Firebase,
we developed a strategy to grant discounts
to these users in a progressive way.
I would advise other developers
to utilize all the tools available through
Google Play Console.
Implement the grace period
to reduce involuntary churns,
employ the introductory price
in order to offer discounts
for users who aren’t subscribed yet,
keep working on the app’s quality
and build an app with an excellent usability.
Quality has been foundational
to the development of our business.